Столична автостанція - тут завжди людно.
Транспорт рушає в усі куточки України.
Звичайні маршрутки, які щодня курсують між містами й селами.
Є проблема: самі перевізники визнають, що більше половини з них не відповідають критеріям безпеки.
Що не так зі звичним усім транспортом?
Водії в його безпечності майже не сумніваються.
Найбезпечніший транспорт Бо їде 90 км в час, не перевищує швидкість.
Або ж віджартовуються…
Наскільки безпечно ви почуваєтеся, коли їздите?
Ну, безпечно ж ніхто ніколи не почувається, правильно?
Ви ходите тут, а раптом дах падати буде?..
На зимову гуму всі начебто перейшли вчасно.
А гума яка у вас стоїть?
- Зимова, все як треба.
Попробуйте пальчиком. Отуди вглиб. Ну як?
- Хороша.
- Якісна. Не лиса.
Пасажирський транспорт має проходити техогляд кожні пів року.
Техогляд проходили?
- Так, кожен квартал проходимо. До 25 квітня, дивіться. Раз на півроку.
Хоча підтвердити це не всі готові.
До механіка, будь ласка. Це він все описує.
- Ви проходили техогляд?
- Льогко.
- А коли?
- Сьогодні вранці.
- Вранці? А покажете документ?
- А хто ви такі, щоб я вам показував?
Але є дещо, чого з першого погляду чи навіть у документах не побачиш.
Більшість цих "бусів" мали би перевозити вантажі, а не людей.
Їх переобладнали під пасажирські, бо так дешевше.
Саме така "перероблена" маршрутка зіткнулася з фурою на Чернігівщині.
"Минуле" транспорту з'ясувала перевірка мінінфрастуктури.
У ДТП - 13 загиблих, 11 людей померли на місці.
Фахівці кажуть: жертв могло би бути менше, якби в транспорті були паски безпеки, а сидіння були закріплені надійно.
Від колишніх вантажних бусів такого годі чекати.
Паски безпеки не передбачені конструкцією, а сидіння нашвидкуруч прикручені до підлоги.
Паски безпеки є?
- Звісно.
- Тут є, а у пасажирів?
- Тут у нас чистий пасажир їде, сідушки - чистий "пасажир".
- А як вони прикріплені сідушки, наскільки міцно?
- Ой, наскрізь болтом і знизу гайка. Пасажир не улетить!
Хто ж може виявити "перероблену" "маршрутку"?
Міжміський транспорт контролює державний орган - "Укртрансбезпека".
Інспектори відомства регулярно влаштовують рейдові перевірки.
І регулярно - ловлять порушників: водіїв без страхового полісу чи без "свіжого" техогляду.
Так, це прострочений, це теж прострочений.
Відсутній страховий поліс на момент перевірки.
А де ви медогляд проходили? - Та..
Карають і тих, хто їздить не за встановленими маршрутами
- тобто підбирає пасажирів під мостами й на зупинках, звичайно ж, без квитка.
Зараз, Олександр Павлович, буде складено акт, і ви поїдете далі.
- І шо я буду с етім актом дєлать?
- Ви нічого. А перевізник ваш, що не забезпечив вас необхідними документами
буде запрошений комісію до теруправління "Укртрансбезпеки".
Алло, Слава, ну шо, тут оказиваєтся схема маршрута, надо було академгородок…
За такі порушення перевізники платитимуть чималий штраф - 17 тисяч гривень.
Але виявити переобладнані маршрутки інспектори не можуть.
Адже дивляться на документи, а вони у такого транспорту зазвичАй у порядку.
Ось документ, загальний автобус, не ми його видавали.
Такий транспорт реєструють як пасажирський, на безпекові нюанси на техогляді дивляться крізь пальці.
Як наслідок - папери в порядку, безпека - ні.
Автобуси переобладнують з вантажних на пасажирські і, звісно, вони просто не призначені для цього.
Але якщо вони переобладнані і є свідоцтво про реєстрацію транспортного засобу,
яке їм видали сервісні центри, то це не є вже порушення, значить - його узаконили.
Експерти кажуть: із цього замкненого кола є вихід -
посилити контроль і перевіряти технічний стан транспорту не лише під час реєстрації,
а й коли він безпосередньо виїздить на дорогу.
І головне - під час конкурсу, коли перевізники "змагаються" за маршрут.
Серед документів, які надають на конкурс, нині є, приміром, сертифікат екологічної безпеки, але не технічної.
Якщо знадобиться сертифікація, то такий транспорт не буде сертифікований як пасажирський.
Зараз цього не вимагають, це не обов'язкова вимога.
Відповідно, з'являються транспортні засоби, які були переобладнані, але переобладнання не виявили.
Цю вимогу треба зробити обов'язковою. Зрозуміло, що такий транспорт небезпечний.
Але переобладнані маршрутки - далеко не єдина небезпека на українських дорогах.
Ось, здавалося б, ідеальний пасажирський автобус.
Тут завод-виробник це робив, не самі переробили, тому тут сидіння капітально стоїть.
Є паски безпеки, аварійні люки.
Кожне сидіння ось з пасками безпеки, проходить техогляд, це все перевіряється з одного боку і з іншого - для кожного пасажира.
Пан Василь - водій цього автобуса.
За кермом пасажирського транспорту більше 30 років.
Каже, головне для безпеки на таких далеких маршрутах - відпочинок водія.
Тому з ним у рейс ідуть ще двоє напарників.
Головне - щоб відпочинок був. Я вже трохи поїздив, то навіть якщо відпочив, то з п'ятої до сьомої ранку тебе все одно хилить,
так що треба в цей час чи мінятися, чи якось цей час перечекати.
Водії, які засинають за кермом, - одна з найпоширеніших причин аварій на міжміському й міжнародному транспорті, кажуть експерти.
До неї додають ще одну - банальну - перевищення швидкості.
Ця проблема добре вирішується за допомогою обмежувачів швидкості.
Це пристрої, які вбудовуються в штатне обладнання й не дають автомобілю розвивати швидкість, більшу за встановлену.
Друга причина - це режим відпочинку водіїв.
Дану проблему теж можна значно зменшити за допомогою тахографів -
це пристрої, які записують режим роботи й відпочинку водіїв.
Треба посилити державний контроль за технічним станом і гарантувати,
аби спеціалісти, які його проводять, проходили якісну підготовку. Зараз цього немає.
Спеціалістів, які можуть перевіряти якісно і кваліфіковано, немає.
На брак кадрів скаржаться і в Укртрансбезпеці.
Аби змінити ситуацію, восени цьогоріч набрали дві сотні нових інспекторів з усієї країни для навчання.
Водіїв і перевізників сподіваються стимулювати штрафами.
З 1 жовтня набули чинності зміни до законодавства, і значно піднялися штрафи за відсутність документів,
обов'язкових для перевізника і для водія, який здійснює перевезення, з 1700 до 17 тисяч гривень.
Так, результат є, перевізники стали ретельніше ставитися до того, щоб були документи.
Вони також сприяють комфорту і безпеці.
Після аварії на Чернігівщині в уряді анонсували кілька законодавчих ініціатив,
аби виправити ситуацію з безпекою автоперевезень в Україні.
Зокрема, обіцяють суворіше карати водіїв і власників автомобілів, які їздять на лисій гумі.
Крім того, в Раді вже зареєстрували законопроєкти, якими хочуть заборонити
на міжміських і приміських маршрутах транспорт без пасків безпеки.
За порушення планують карати штрафами в 34 тисячі гривень.
Та закон і нині вимагає паски безпеки для автобусів, які їздять на маршрути довжиною понад 50 кілометрів.
Утім, як ми встигли помітити, дотримуються законів далеко не всі.